-Our next guest won Best Actress
at Cannes Film Festival
for her work
in the critically acclaimed film
"The Worst Person in the World,"
which is in theaters
February 4th.
Let's take a look.
Please welcome to the show
Renate Reinsve.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show!
-Thank you.
Thank you.
-Congratulations on this movie.
This is a wonderful film.
It's a beautiful film.
It tells the story
of a fascinating woman
and you won Best Actress
at Cannes.
What has this journey been like?
-It's been something.
[ Laughter ]
I don't --
I can't put it into words, yet,
because it's like
I'm sitting here now.
It's terrifying.
It's wonderful.
Like it's all the words.
I don't know, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-The thing I keep reading --
and I'm wondering
if it's true --
that you had decided,
the day before --
This is your first lead role.
The day before you were offered
this film,
you had decided to quit acting.
-Yes, I had like this big moment
where I laid in bed,
and I kind of like
this big moment of, "I'm done.
I'm finished."
And then, the day after,
he called me for this role.
It's very strange.
Weird.
-What was your backup plan?
-[ Laughs ]
It was carpenting.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Yeah.
So almost the same as acting.
[ Laughter ]
Almost the same.
-So this is a director,
Joachim Trier --
I think I'm saying that right?
-Yes, you were.
-You had been
in a previous movie of his,
called "Oslo August 31st,"
something like that?
-Yeah.
-Beautiful film as well.
You had one line in that film.
-Yeah.
-You must've made
quite an impact.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Do you want to do
the line for us?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-[ U.S. accent ]
Let's go to the party.
-So good.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Thanks.
-So good.
[ Cheering ]
I mean, I remember.
-But, recently, someone told me
I also have another line
that I forgot.
It was improvised.
It's "I have water in my nose."
Also a great line.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
It wasn't even written for you.
-No!
-That's what you bring
to a project.
-I know!
[ Laughter ]
-Now, I'm wondering --
because he came to you and said,
"I wrote this part for you."
-Yeah.
-The the movie is called
"The Worst Person in the World."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I mean, that must've been
a real like good news, bad news.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
The first thing I thought was,
"My ex is going to be
very happy."
[ Laughter ]
My face is going to be
on a poster
and it's going to be
"The Worst Person in the World."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-I didn't even think of that.
He must've been like,
"What did I tell you?"
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-You're obviously not
the worst person in the world.
In this film, you are, I think,
a complicated person,
which are the most
interesting to play.
It's a beautifully shot film.
There's a moment where everyone
freezes and you run through.
You're in motion.
Everyone else is frozen.
Not CGI, correct?
-No, nothing.
He wanted to do it
like old-school.
Joachim, I mean, yeah.
-So what does that mean,
that a bunch of other
sort of secondary actors,
extras,
have to just
stand perfectly still?
-Well, they were like
rehearsing.
They were standing there,
looked very good.
You've seen it, you know.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah. And I was running
up and down and then, suddenly,
we saw more people joined in.
So, and then they had
to stay the whole day.
[ Laughter ]
And so we actually got
more people in during the day.
-So this is just people walking
around Oslo who are like,
"Alright, I'll stand still
for a big movie"?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah. They were annoyed
because we had to like
stop traffic.
Oslo is very small, so,
if you block off a street,
it's like half the city.
[ Laughter ]
So, everyone was like waiting
for us to finish
so they can cross the street
and then they just joined in,
instead, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, I would imagine
maybe they're frustrated
at the time
because their street
gets shut down.
But, for a Norwegian film
to get international acclaim
and attention like this has,
are people in Norway
intensely proud of how
the film's been received?
-Yeah, so proud.
Like I feel that we all --
Like Norway did it.
Now, we're like --
[ Laughter ]
We -- Yes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah, give it up for Norway.
-Everyone is happy.
[ Laughs ]
-I mean, when you go
to someplace like Cannes,
do you get to meet, run into,
other actors that you've
respected over the years?
-Yeah. I, uh -- [ Laughs ]
Yeah.
I had this moment.
I think it was the day
after we showed the film
and I walked past
Tilda Swinton.
She's, you know.
-That's a real good one.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then I walked past
and then I kind of backed up
because I was, "Is that her?"
And I turned and I looked
and I waited until she saw me
and I gave her like a bow.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I don't know what.
And then, I thought
she was going to be like,
"Oh, thank you,"
but she was like this --
[ Laughter ]
And then I heard
she just saw the movie.
-Right.
-I ran out after that, yeah.
-That's very Cinderella.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-You deserve bows as well.
Congratulations on the film
and thank you so much
for making time for us.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thank you.
-You guys, that's
Renata Reinsve, everybody!
"The Worst Person in the World"
is in theaters February 4th.